madame la présidente madame la ministre
excellence mes chers collègues
je voudrais très sincèrement vous
remercier monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires européennes de
nous le donner l'occasion aujourd'hui de
voter une résolution qui affirme le
soutien de notre assemblée à l'Ukraine
lors de nos débats l'initiative du
gouvernement
Jean-Louis bourge et Frédéric petit ont
rappelé notre position les députés du
groupe démocrates sont et resteront aux
côtés du peuple ukrainien dans leur
combat pour la liberté
ce soutien indéfectible et ancien depuis
la Révolution 2004 se retrouve dans les
couleurs de notre famille politique
cette orange symbole de la démocratie
ukrainienne mais il se retrouve aussi et
surtout dans les actes de nos
représentants
dans cette assemblée comme au Parlement
européen au Parlement européen ou nos
collègues de l'Europe ensemble ont
soutenu toutes les aides financières à
l'Ukraine les sanctions contre la Russie
ou encore récemment la reconnaissance de
cette dernière comme état terroriste
à la différence du RN et de LFI qui
n'ont pas jugé utile de voter pour cette
prise de position forte
lorsqu'on se prétend défenseur de la
démocratie il faut savoir aligner les
paroles et les actes
mais même qui affichent
leurs scrupules lorsqu'il s'agit de
voter un soutien effectif aux Ukrainiens
sont aussi les premiers à critiquer la
réaction européenne et française comme
nous l'avons vu ce soir et il faut le
rappeler l'Union européenne et les États
membres ont été au rendez-vous pour
soutenir nos voisins Ukrainiens à
travers la prise de sanction inédite
dans un temps record contre les
dirigeants russes à travers le soutien
financier militaire humanitaire ou
encore l'accueil de réfugiés qu'il
faudra pérenniser les Européens ont
répondu présent alors que la facilité
européenne pour la paix a fourni une
aide à hauteur de 8 milliards d'euros
jusqu'ici qui se poursuivra en 2023 les
pays ont également contribué
individuellement c'est le cas de la
France avec ces fameux cas non César des
missiles Milan crotale ou encore des
véhicules blindés
à cet effort s'ajoutera en 2023 une aide
exceptionnelle de 200 millions d'euros
pour des équipements militaires français
un renforcement au soutien à l'Ukraine
que nous avons souhaité dans le cadre du
PLF R2
après 9 mois de guerre je pense ce soir
au centaines de milliers de familles
ukrainiennes qui sont aujourd'hui privés
d'eau d'électricité de chauffage à la
veille d'un hiver je forme le vœu que si
nous devons continuer d'aider lucrènes à
se défendre nous devons également
pouvoir lui fournir une assistance
technique garantissant à sa population
un accès aux biens de première nécessité
comme la France l'a fait avec l'envoi de
100 générateurs électriques il y a
quelques jours ce soutien inébranlable
couplé à l'extraordinaire courage des
Ukrainiens c'est ce qui permet
aujourd'hui à l'Ukraine de gagner du
terrain et d'infliger les défaites à
celles qui se présentaient jusqu'à lors
comme la deuxième armée du monde cette
guerre a certes révélé des dissensions
dans la famille européenne en lien
notamment avec la dépendance énergétique
de chacun de ses membres bien plus forte
en dehors de nos frontières que dans
notre pays mais ce conflit de haute
intensité a surtout démontré une volonté
d'agir ensemble pour relever les défis
sur le plan diplomatique de
l'indépendance énergétique et de la
transition écologique cette nécessité
d'union n'a d'ailleurs pas échappé aux
Ukrainiens qui savent que la
construction d'un ensemble fort
indépendant démocratique et la seule
réponse aux enjeux d'aujourd'hui enfin
mes chers collègues les horreurs de ce
conflit mettent à l'épreuve notre
humanité et nos valeurs quoi qu'en dit
certains poutine au fil nous
n'oublierons pas les victimes civiles
les blessés les femmes violées les
enfants arrachés à leurs parents
n'oublions pas bout de chat n'oublions
pas les crèches les écoles les hôpitaux
bombardés des crimes de guerre qui
devront être jugés bien évidemment les
députés démocrates soutiendront cette
proposition de résolution je vous
remercie merci